hey what's up everyone its Warren and we
have a new round of official Avengers
in-game promotional art and along with
the new promotional art we have a new
Avengers in-game logo that is just
shattered to pieces just like all of the
other promotional art that we've gotten
for Avengers in-game in the past this
promo art only features the remaining
Avengers that are still alive after the
snap if you caught my video yesterday
you'll know that the Russo brothers and
Marvel themselves are doing everything
that they possibly can to keep any
possible spoilers away in the trailers
and in the promo art so we don't learn
too much about what's going to happen in
Avengers in game the new shattered logo
that we have isn't too different than
the one that we saw for the very first
Avengers in-game trailer the logo being
shattered is very fitting right now
considering the state that the Avengers
are in as well as the rest of the world
is in after Thanos is snap everything is
pretty much shattered after the snap so
very fitting new logo besides from the
new logo we have seen most of these
pictures of the Avengers in previous
concept art we do have a couple of new
looks at Thanos that we haven't seen
before and of course he is wearing his
armor in these pictures I do really like
this new style for each individual
Avengers promo art I really like how to
give all of them different colors and
these are most likely going to be used
for posters and t-shirts besides that
nothing is really revealed here like I
said Marvel's marketing team is trying
to keep everything as secretive as
possible for Avengers in game again the
shattered broken logo is very fitting
because Thanos has snap left not only
The Avengers but the universe truly
broken and of course we will see The
Avengers try and undo that snap in
Avengers end game so let me know what
you think about this new promo art let
me know which one is your favorite let
me know in the comments down below and a
reminder about my giveaway I'm giving
away 5 imax tickets so you and some
friends can go see Avengers end game if
you'd like to interfere your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and of
course if you're new don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers in game
and Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you